after weeks stuck in this beach town a
few hundred migrants mostly haitians are
finally able to continue their journey
north
while others continue to scramble for a
ferry ticket despite being told they are
sold out until the end of october and
that's because neighboring panama is
only allowing 500 to enter the country
each day
mario saint-juice and his family are
among the lucky ones who are finally
able to leave after a 45-day wait
and locals take advantage of us being
stuck here while a colombian buys a kilo
of rice for the equivalent in pesos of
less than two dollars they charge us
seven or eight dollars and that's just
wrong
he's worried now of having to cross the
notoriously dangerous tyrion jungle only
to end up being deported
we know there's a lot of crime on the
other side armed thieves risk of sexual
abuse i have a family member that's been
through that but returning is not an
option return to what i already spent
ten thousand dollars to get here i'd
need to spend the same to return
like many haitians here he settled in
chile after a devastating earthquake
ravaged this country in 2010
but the economic crisis following kovitz
pushed him back on the road
at least 22 000 migrants are staying in
the cocle some can afford to stay in
houses or hotels others are forced to
pitch tents on the beach
to try to end this crisis colombian
authorities are now openly trying to
dissuade the migrants from continuing
their journey insisting on the risks
that lie ahead and also telling them
that they will likely be deported if
they reach the united states or even
stop the mexico the government has also
ordered travel companies to stop selling
bus tickets to migrants entering
colombia from ecuador
the scare tactics are working some
asians have decided to return to their
host countries none would go on camera
but they said they either ran out of
money or are too scared to be deported
back to haiti
almost 200 people are now returning
every day and they're communicating to
their friends and relatives that it's
not worth trying to do this anymore
with the news tightening around them
some are left with no option but admit
their attempts have failed even when
they have nothing to return to
alessandra
al jazeera necoclear